le nouveau ministre de la santé madame
simone veil a l'intention de s'informer
contraitement des problèmes sociaux
posés à son ministère pour une de ses
premières sorties elle a choisi de se
rendre à suresnes dans un foyer de
jeunes travailleurs et dans un foyer de
personnes âgées je crois qu'il était bon
qu'un ministre la santé montre qu'il
était bien sûr soucieux de la santé de
tous les français s'intéressent aux
hôpitaux mais qu'il y avait aussi dans
son département ministériel tout le
secteur social et dans ce secteur social
il ya dans le tout premier lieu
naturellement les jeunes viennent pas et
les vieillards puisque la direction de
l'aide sociale se préoccupe de toute
l'assistance à apporter à succès rente
catégories de personnes alors pour ce
qui le concerne les jeunes j'ai visité à
un foyer de jeunes travailleurs parce
que c'est une catégorie de jeunes qui a
particulièrement besoin qu'on s'occupe
d'elle il s'agit de deux jeunes qui
souvent ont rompu leurs liens avec leurs
familles qui sont trouvés en difficulté
ou qui ne gagnent pas encore
suffisamment pour procéder pour les
seuls dans la vie et c'est vraiment je
crois le rôle de notre société de les
aider de le prendre en charge pour
qu'ensuite puisse se développer dans les
meilleures conditions les aider pour
recommencer dès qu'ils seront mariés
exposeront leurs propres tels
le foyer des personnes âgées ensuite
reçu le 8 de madame veil accompagné de
monsieur le noir le secrétaire d'état à
l'action sociale
alors ici au contraire c'est l'autre
côté c'est la fin de la vie qu'on essaye
d'améliorer je prouve que ce foyer il
faudrait qu'il y ait beaucoup
d'estantens est très intéressant de le
visiter pour voir justement ce qu'on
pouvait faire pour que les personnes qui
toute la vie on travaillait qui ont été
nos aînés puissent trouver une
vieillesse heureuse dans les meilleures
conditions vous avez besoin de faire un
effort dans ce sens là mais sûrement je
crois qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup à faire et que les places
d'hospice dont on dispose sont très
insuffisantes je crois qu'ici ce que
nous allons devoir c'est un exemple de
ce qu'on peut faire je crois d'ailleurs
qu'il a d'autres il faut diversifier